all day here on 8 news now we are taking
you inside nellis air force base it is a
major employer here in the valley and
chances are you might know someone who
works there
there are nearly 12 thousand military
and more than 3
000 civilians and contractors on the
base nellis well known for training some
of the best airmen in the entire country
orco mana shows us how the weapons
school provides them
top-notch preparation in this special
report
physically challenging mentally
challenging a one-of-a-kind classroom
the united states air force weapons
school at nellis air force base molding
the best and brightest to take the skies
by storm
what we do is train our students to
become tactical experts
in their combat specialty major joseph
butler is an instructor at the weapons
school
he says the doctorate level course runs
twice a year with anywhere from 100 to
130 airmen from
all over the country in each class after
a couple weeks of academics
from radar theory through weaponrying
the whole the whole gamut students get
crucial hands-on experience that
includes mid-air battle sequences
mock deployment of missiles and live
fire operations
we start moving into more tailored
ground events simulations live flying
airmen here at the weapons school go
through about five and a half months of
training
all culminating in what's known as the
weapon school integration
that is the pinnacle of the students
time here at the weapon school it's the
crucible
as it's called happens during the final
four weeks of the course students
integrate multiple weapons systems
across the air
land space and cyber domains you're
going to have one of our students
at the weapons school as that leader for
the joint force
the whole point is to produce top airmen
who after graduation can be trusted
advisors to their commanders and true
leaders
they will be in charge of preparing
their squadron for war
nellis air force base providing the
perfect place to practice with the
nevada test and training range
they are able to now actually go out and
do their techniques their tactics their
procedures
to the full extent against an adversary
that most best replicates what they
might
face in combat the fact that we have the
nils test and training range just up the
way
is a huge benefit the space and the
school combined
creating a formidable force having that
person being the expert
that's able to fly that's a little
mission plan take lessons learned
and lead is something that you only get
here at the at the weapons school
reporting from nellis air force base
orco mana 8 news now